you're creating a very basic home with a
budget builder know these fundamental
tips one make sure that your living
spaces if you're in the southern
hemisphere are on the northern side you
want your living spaces to be flooded
with natural light and heat up the most
throughout the day if you're in the
northern hemisphere that is obviously
flipped and most of these tips are
flipped as well because it goes with the
solar passive nature of the sun number
two goes hand in hand if you're in the
southern hemisphere and the northern
hemisphere so for the southern
hemisphere your living areas are in the
north which logically makes your
sleeping quarters in the south of the
building humans tend to naturally
gravitate to colder sleeping spaces
because it allows us to have a much
deeper sleep especially in a warm
comfortable bed so repositioning your
private spaces and your sleeping
quarters to the southern side of the
house can make a huge huge difference in
the overall design of the architecture